merci à tous d'être avec nous et
aujourd'hui en ce début d'émission doit
décider bien sûr de rendre hommage à
charles aznavour charles aznavour qui
nous a quittés aujourd'hui à 94 ans
alors pour les plus jeunes qui nous
regardent
mais c'est vrai que charles aznavour
tout le monde ne connaîtrai recyclage et
les middle voilà tout le monde a une
chanson de charles aznavour dans la tête
on vous a quand même fait en résumé une
petite vidéo pour vous montrer qu'ils
étaient charles aznavour
on va s'intéresser à charles aznavour
pendant toute cette première heure et
après bien sûr on reviendra sur tout ce
qui s'est passé sur les médias notamment
avec danse avec les stars et le jt des
médias alors aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
de monde 1 voilà autour de la table
parce que on à bernard montiel qui a
plein de choses à nous dire sur charles
aznavour daniel moreau qui a écrit un
livre sur lui on a mon ami jacques
sanchez aussi qui est spécialiste rien
sur de la musique etc et je suis très
content que vous soyez là est notre
invité on l'a gardé ce soit parce que
vous voulez qu'ils restent avec nous
c'est augustine galiana qu'on aime
beaucoup version musculaire le live ce
soir et qui reviendra nous faire à la
ville reste avec l'une des séries
charles aznavour c'est ça
la nuit dernière une étoile de la
chanson française s'est éteinte à l'âge
de 94 ans celui qui chantait
[Musique]
son effet
l'infatigable charles aznavour né en
1924 à paris de parents arméniens
s'apprêtait à entamer une ultime tournée
apogée d'une carrière incroyable malgré
une reconnaissance tardive à 33 ans pour
celui qui se
et depuis des décennies charles est
entré dans le coeur des français de
toutes les générations et n'est jamais
redescendu du haut de la fiche avec plus
de 1400 chansons des chansons dans
lesquelles il nous parlait avec
mélancolie d'un témoin
gens ne peuvent pas connaître
des chansons qui en 70 ans de carrière
ont marqué la vie de chacun d'entre nous
depuis des années le temps semblait ne
plus avoir d'emprise sur charles
aznavour à tel point qu on s'imaginer
qu'il disait vrai lorsqu'il chantait
hier encore j'avais 20 ans je caressais
le temps honoré d'une étoile sur
hollywood boulevard en 2017
aznavour restera à jamais dans nos
coeurs celui des arméniens des français
et du monde entier
bref un artiste
voila j'aimerais d'abord
[Musique]
ça m'a un peu de moi
depuis charles aznavour on pense bien
sûr très fort à sa famille j'ai une très
grosse pensée pour la fille de charles
aznavour qui est vraiment une amie très
proche katia à qui je fais un énorme
bisou je pense très fort à elle est bien
sûr mon meilleur ami jean rachid voilà
qui est le le le voilà le nombre à le
gendre de charles aznavour à qui je
pense très fort et à qui je fais un
énorme bisou alors charles aznavour 94
ans et il était venu nous voir un dans
touche pas à mon poste il est
exceptionnel j'ai passé mois des dd je
n'ai que charles aznavour ou charles
aznavour aujourd'hui il est exceptionnel
il voulait absolument donner des idées
sur la telline donné plein d'idées sur
l'émission nous regardent et très
souvent le soir voilà dans touche pas à
mon poste
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
jour triste pour nous il nous a quittés
à 94 ans et c'est vrai que pour nous et
charles aznavour est éternel